es gibt ja einige in diesem Land ich
will jetzt keinen konkret angucken die
sagen ständig dass wir uns einen Weg aus
der Klimakrise erfinden werden der
deutsche Ingenieur regelt das schon mit
Förderung Innovation und Genialität und
dann können wir weitermachen wie bisher
und tatsächlich wurden ja schon einige
geniale Lösungen gefunden z.B können wir
das CO2 einfach aus der Luft
herausfiltern mit sogenannten direct Air
capture and carpen storage kurz daccs
Anlagen eine super Idee können wir uns
jetzt also zurücklehnen weiter
Verbrenner Auto fahren und in den Urlaub
fliegen weil diese Anlagen den
Klimawandel schon wieder umkehren werden
nun wir haben mit dem Chief technology
Officer von der Firma gesprochen die die
erste kommerzielle daccs-anlage der Welt
betreibt und er hat uns leider eine
ernüchternde Einordnung gegeben
welchen Beitrag solche co2-sauger
tatsächlich leisten können und wie man
die Potenzial voll ausschöpfen kann
genau darüber sprechen wir jetzt
wenn wir das Pariser Klimaabkommen
einhalten wollen dann müssen wir nicht
nur die Emissionen beenden sondern
darüber hinaus auch historische
Emissionen wieder rückgängig machen
aktuell imitieren wir jedes Jahr über 37
Gigatonnen CO2 dagegen stehen 2
Gigatonnen die wir mit Karben dioxide
removel Maßnahmen wieder ausgleichen
nice aber das ist zu wenig außerdem
setzen wir hier bei hauptsächlich auf
die Hilfe der Natur z.B wenn wir Bäume
pflanzen diese Methoden sind aber leider
nicht so ausbaufähig wie sie sein
müssten allein schon weil die Wälder
wegen des Klimawandels nicht gut wachsen
deshalb müssen wir zusätzlich auf neue
Technologien in industrielle Maßstab
setzen das Problem die Gesamtleistung
dieser Technologien beträgt zur Zeit
erst rund
0,002 Giga Tonnen pro Jahr bis 2050 das
sind nur noch 27 Jahre müsste das
mindestens auf das
1.300-fache Anwachsen das ist die
Einschätzung des state of Karben der
Report basierend den Szenarien des
Weltklimarats was dafür passieren muss
darüber habe ich mit Carlos Härtel CTO
der Firma kleinworks gesprochen
climworks und ihre Partner haben sich
auf daccs spezialisiert
daccs besteht aus zwei Schritten einmal
das Auffangen von CO2 aus der Luft das
Direct Air capture DAC und im zweiten
Schritt das wegspeichern des CO2 Karben
storage
direct Air capture Anlagen saugen viel
Luft mit Ventilatoren ein und binden das
CO2 dann mit speziellen Filtern
Filtermaterialien für da der capture
gibt es unterschiedliche Wesentlichen
ist es immer so dass die Materialien
irgendwie einen basischen Charakter
haben das CO2 selber hat eine Charakter
eine Säure und die beiden Materialien
kommen dann natürlicherweise zusammen es
gibt sehr starke basische Stoffe und es
gibt schwächere wir arbeiten mit denen
die etwas schwächer sind die haben den
Vorteil dass man sie bei niedrigeren
Temperaturen wieder regenerieren kann
regenerieren bedeutet dass man das CO2
wieder aus dem Filter entfernt danach
kann man ihn wieder verwenden im Fall
von kleinen works muss der Filter auf
ungefähr 100 Grad erhitzt werden das ist
verglichen mit anderen Filtern wenig
aber immer noch ein großer
Energieaufwand Wärme und Strom müssen
natürlich CO2 Kanal sein sonst würde man
mehr CO2 auspusten als wieder einfangen
deshalb steht climworks erste
kommerzielle Anlage in der Nähe eines
geothermie-kraftwerks in Island Island
ist aber auch deshalb ein geeigneter
Standort weil man das Kohlendioxid dort
permanent wegspeichern kann das kann man
prinzipiell auf verschiedene Arten und
Weisen tun zum Beispiel in
Gesteinsschichten mit Grundwasser oder
in ehemaligen Erdgaslagerstätten CO2
bindet aber auch an bestimmten
Mineralien eine Partnerfirma von
kleinworks verpresst das CO2 deshalb in
eine Basaltschicht im Untergrund und
dieses Gestein dort hat genau die
mineralische Zusammensetzung die es
braucht damit aus CO2 in relativ kurzer
Zeit selber wieder fällt wird
carbonatgestein weiße Kristalle die man
wenn man Bohrkerne zieht aus dem Basalt
auch sehr gut nachweisen kann als feine
Einlagerungen in den Größen
grundbestandes die Bildung von
carbonatgestein dauert in der Natur
meist hunderte sogar Tausende von Jahren
in Island soll das wegen der besonderen
Eigenschaften der Lager aber in nur zwei
Jahren passieren und wenn es einmal
gebunden ist löst es sich auch nicht
mehr auf das CO2 ist dann permanent
gespeichert natürlich muss man aber auch
dafür sorgen dass das verpresste CO2
nicht aus dem Boden entweichen kann zum
Beispiel durch natürliche Risse oder
neue Bohrlöcher das ist eine weitere
technische Herausforderung okay die
Technologie funktioniert soweit außerdem
ist der Bereich direct Air capture der
mit den meisten Innovationen unter den
cda-methoden aber wir müssen Karben Dax
hat removal im großen Stil betreiben
also im richtig großen Stil
geht das
[Musik]
climworksanlage Orca auf Island ist die
erste kommerziell betriebene dax-anlage
der Welt die Accs sie entzieht der
Atmosphäre 4000 Tonnen CO2 pro Jahr
damit ist sie eine der größten
technischen cda-anlagen die es gibt aber
im Vergleich zu den Mengen die wir in
den nächsten Jahrzehnten der Atmosphäre
entnehmen müssten ist das leider gar
nichts um die Ziele des Pariser
Klimaabkommens zu erreichen muss eine
ganze CDA Industrie aufgebaut werden die
gute Nachricht es gibt genug
Speichermöglichkeiten allein das
Basaltgestein auf Island könnte laut
climb works große Teile aller
europäischen Emissionen für die nächsten
100 Jahre aufnehmen
aber es gibt auch noch einige Hürden zu
nehmen ich würde sagen die Flaschenhälse
sind dreierlei zum einen ist der
wichtigste die Technologie wir sind noch
lange nicht da dass man sagen könnte die
Technologie ist ausgereift die Kosten
sind ausreichend niedrig die
zuverlässigkeiten sind ausreichend hoch
das muss innerhalb der nächsten fünf bis
zehn Jahren passieren der zweite
Flaschenhals ist die Energieversorgung
die eben nicht immer da ist wo ideale
Lagerstätten sind wo ich das CO2
Verbrechen kann in Island wird kein
extra Geothermie Kraftwerk für uns
gebaut sondern wir können das nutzen was
dort vor Ort sowieso noch verfügbar ist
wenn man die Anleitung aber noch
deutlich größer machen muss man über
eigene Energieprojekte nachdenken der
dritte Flaschenhals ist Zulieferkette
die Komponenten die wir heute verbauen
sind eigentlich alle Spezialmaschinen
bauen irgendwann muss das ein reguläres
Produkt sein was zu bekannten
Spezifikationen in großen Stückzahlen
zuverlässig und kostengünstig gefertigt
wird diese Zulieferketten gibt es heute
nicht wir brauchen also weitere
Innovationen standardisierte Bauteile
und entsprechende Zulieferer und eine
erfolgreiche Energiewende in Deutschland
würde new works zurzeit keine Anlage
bauen weil der deutsche Strommix noch zu
viel CO2 ausstößt aber natürlich braucht
es vor allem Geld im Moment gibt es bei
kleinen works wohl eine große Nachfrage
microsoft will zum Beispiel ihre
aktuellen Emissionen ausgleichen und
auch alle vorherigen Emissionen seit der
Gründung rückgängig machen andere
Softwareunternehmen wollen ihre
Emissionen auch ausgleichen außerdem
Versicherungen Banken und
Beratungsunternehmen dabei geht es
sicherlich vor allem auch um den guten
Ruf die Menschen wollen einfach Produkte
von unbedenklichen Firmen kaufen und in
unbedenkliche Firmen investieren und
ganz sicher möchte auch die Belegschaft
für eine unbedenkliche Firma arbeiten
aber solche Unternehmen betreiben vor
allem Büros und IT-Infrastruktur das
sind also nicht die großen Fische im CO2
emissionstesteich die ganz großen
Industrieunternehmen das sind
Zementfabriken das sind Stahlwerke das
ist der gesamte Energie Sektor mit
großen Kraftwerkskapazitäten für diese
Firmen wäre es heute relativ sinnlos
sich solche removel Dienstleistungen
einzukaufen weil das natürlich nur einen
unglaublich kleinen Teil ihrer eigenen
Emissionen abdecken könnte diese Firmen
werden zunächst einmal durch das
Aufhören des imitierens auf netto 0
kommen müssen und das ist ein
längerfristiger Prozess da können wir
Ihnen keine Hilfestellung leisten aber
sobald der Strom CO2 neutral ist gibt es
keine Emissionen mehr und ohne
Emissionen gibt es auch keinen
Emissionshandel mehr der CDA finanzieren
könnte das ist aber genau der Punkt an
dem CO2 remove besonders wichtig wird
ihr erinnert euch keine Emissionen mehr
zu haben reicht nicht wir müssen
zusätzlich historisches CO2 aus der
Atmosphäre herausholen deshalb müssen
starten Gesetze machen damit sie die
auch dann noch auf einem hohen Niveau
weiter betrieben werden kann Carlos
Härtel stellt sich das so vor dass den
Betreiber von cda-anlagen ein Festpreis
für jede Tonne entnommenes CO2
zugesichert wird ähnlich wie Betreibern
von privaten Photovoltaikanlagen
Festpreise für ihren Strom versprochen
werden
wie ihr wisst bin ich großer Fan der
E-Mobilität und fahre auch selber E-Auto
da wir mit der Verkehrswende deutlich
CO2 einsparen können das gar nicht erst
in der Atmosphäre landet was viele aber
nicht wissen ist dass man sich mit einem
E-Auto über die sogenannte THG Prämie
mehrere hundert Euro zurückholen kann
mit der THG Prämie will die Regierung
quasi Umwelt schützendes Verhalten
belohnen und dazu gehört auch das Fahren
von E-Autos aber wenn man sich das Geld
dann vom Grund holen will ist das sehr
bürokratisch dauert ziemlich lange und
ist auch ein bisschen nervig und genau
da kommt Lucifer ins Spiel juicify ist
ein Bremer start up dass dir hilft über
eine Online-Anmeldung schneller an deine
thg-prämie für dein E-Auto zu kommen die
übernehmen dann auch den ganzen
Verwaltungsaufwand und überweisen das
Geld deutlich schneller deswegen haben
sie auch den Award für den schnellsten
Prämien Auszahlung bekommen wie hoch
eure Prämie dann genau ist das
orientiert sich am aktuellen Marktwert
der THG Quote wenn ihr das ganze dann
macht dann habt ihr auch noch die
Möglichkeit entweder 25 oder 50 € von
eurer Prämie für ein ökosozialprojekt zu
spenden und justify verdoppelt diesen
Betrag dann noch mal welche Projektes
gibt das findet ihr unter dem zweiten
Link in der Videobeschreibung und unter
dem ersten Link findet ihr die Anmeldung
und mit dem Link unterstütze dann auch
noch uns und unseren Kanal dankeschön
manche Länder haben große Ambitionen
aber selber noch nicht allzu viel
gemacht derzeit muss man klar sagen dass
die USA sich in eine Führungsrolle
gebracht haben auch dadurch dass sie im
Rahmen der neuen gesetzespakete die ja
gegen Inflation sich richten und
Wiederaufbau bestimmter industrieller
Infrastrukturen in dem Kontext ist auch
sehr viel gemacht worden was das Thema
Carmen und das Thema direct Air capture
unterstützt sind dort beispielsweise 4
sogenannte Hubs also Knotenpunkte aus
Versehen die jeweils mit erheblichen
staatlichen ausgebauten gefördert werden
an diesem Knoten punkten soll
ausschließlich damit aircapture
eingesetzt werden und dann werden dort
auch die entsprechenden senken gleich
mit entwickelt das ist ein Programm was
in der Form heute nur in den USA da ist
wir sehen aber großes Interesse in all
den Ländern die traditionell auch
Rohstoffe gefördert haben fossile
Rohstoffe weil die natürlich auch über
die Technologien verfügen den
umgekehrten Weg zu gehen also ein Gas
mit flüssigter oder gasförmiger Form
wieder unter dem Boden zu bringen
sicherlich noch ein weiter Weg von einer
Ölwirtschaft dann in eine Kabel
Wirtschaft um zu steigen aber man
erkennt das dort das wo das Know-how ist
das Interesse an den Technologien die
wir einsetzen auch entsprechend groß ist
also die Länder die fossile Brennstoffe
gefördert haben wollen nun auch sie die
R als Dienstleistung anbieten die
Anreize für alle anderen Staaten diese
Dienstleistungen dann auch einzukaufen
kennen wir natürlich schon das
verhindern massiver Schäden an unserer
Gesundheit und unserem Wohlstand okay
grundsätzlich scheint es ja möglich zu
sein eine CDA Industrie aufzubauen wenn
genügend politischer Wille besteht der
besteht übrigens noch nicht die
bisherigen Pläne greifen alle viel zu
kurz aber über welche Ausmaße sprechen
wir hier eigentlich
um das Pariser Abkommen einzuhalten
müssen wir von der Zeit zwei Megatonnen
jährlich auf mehrere Gigatonnen kommen
wahrscheinlich so zwischen 2 und 3
Gigatonnen in nur 27 Jahren es gilt für
alle neuen CDA Methoden zusammen Carlos
Härtel könnte sich gut vorstellen dass
DAX fast die Hälfte davon ausmachen
könnte ich glaube dass wir innerhalb der
nächsten fünf bis zehn Jahre die
Millionen Tonnen Rente knacken werden
hoffentlich um knapp nach 20 30 schon im
Bereich von 10 Millionen Tonnen sind und
dann über einen Zeitraum von etwa zwei
Jahrzehnten noch mal einen Faktor 100
wachsen das ist viel ist aber machbar
der norbahnen Energien vor allen Dingen
gewinnt Industrie die haben über ihre
stärksten zwei Jahrzehnte diesen Ausbau
um einen Faktor 100 geschafft wir werden
damit im Bereich um 20 40 herum
vielleicht bei 100 Millionen Tonnen pro
Jahr und im Bereich um 20 50 herum bei
einer Milliarde Tonne im Jahr
damit kämen wir mit allen cda-methoden
zusammen vielleicht auch 5 bis 6
Gigatonnen CO2 Einsparung pro Jahr
weltweit aber wir erinnern uns im Moment
imitieren wir jedes Jahr über 37
Gigatonnen außerdem braucht es für so
ein riesiges Vorhaben natürlich vor
allem Fachkräfte insgesamt gesehen wird
die Industrie irgendwie ähnlich sein wie
das was man heute aus den Erneuerbaren
kennt also auch was die Fachberufe
angeht und was die Ingenieure angeht und
was natürlich die Zulieferketten angeht
und Transportkapazitäten und anderes
manche vergleichen das mit der gesamten
Öl und Gasindustrie heute dass man eine
Industrie aufbauen muss die quasi das
was die ihre Gasindustrie auf dem Boden
geholt und in die Atmosphäre gebracht
hat von dort wieder rausholt und wieder
zurückbringen in den Boden
viele klimaaktivisten möchten über
technische Lösungsansätze am liebsten
gar nicht sprechen dafür gibt es zwei
Gründe zum einen besteht die Gefahr dass
cda-technologien uns dazu verleiten
weiter fossile Energien zu verwenden
frei nach dem Motto irgendwer macht es
nachher schon sauber und das kann sie
die einfach nicht leisten das sagen
selbst Menschen wie Carlos Härtel die
ein wirtschaftliches Interesse an CDA
haben zum anderen bedeutet technisches
aufrüsten gegen die Klimakrise wieder
industrielles Wachstum und industrielles
Wachstum an sich ist ein großes Problem
für die Biodiversität wie wir hier schon
erklärt haben viele finden dass wir uns
auf diese Weise nur Zeit kaufen aber
nicht das eigentliche Problem angehen
aber der wissenschaftliche Konsens ist
eben auch dass wir Carbon dark Set
remove brauchen um die globale Erwärmung
effektiv zu bremsen bekommen nicht
drumherum dabei darf das gefilterte CO2
natürlich auch nicht in neue Produkte
oder Biomasse fließen die am Ende einer
kurzen Lebenszeit dann doch wieder als
CO2 in die Luft gehen looking at you
das CO2 muss möglichst permanent aus der
Luft entfernt werden und das können nur
wenige Verfahren leisten
am wichtigsten finde ich die Erkenntnis
dass wir es uns nicht leisten können
wählerisch zu sein wir müssen einfach
CO2-Emissionen vermeiden wo es geht
unser Lebensstil muss nachhaltiger
werden wir müssen die Ökosysteme wieder
aufbauen auch das speichert CO2 und wir
müssen CO2 mit technischen Methoden Weg
speichern jedes bisschen Treibhausgas
das nicht in der Atmosphäre landet ist
ein wichtiger Beitrag zum abschwächen
der Klimakatastrophe
danke an euch dass ihr bis zum Ende bei
diesem wichtigen Thema dabei geblieben
seid und wie immer vielen Dank fürs
zuschauen und bleibt neugierig euer
Cedric